l'écologie en tant qu'environnement
l'environnemental c'est à dire s'occuper
de tout ce qui est au reboisement
s'occuper de la nature s'occuper des
décharges sauvages des vh eu de tout ce
qui est environnement s'occupait aussi
de la transition énergétique c'est très
important de passer effectivement est
réellement à la transition énergétique
remettre par exemple des leds remettre
des lumières moins énergivore voilà tout
cela il faut absolument tourner la
politique aujourd'hui vais à la
transition énergétique
et puis l'écologie politique c'est aussi
l'écologie financière renégocier les
prêts toxiques revoir comment la dette
peut être renégociés en faveur des
populations les plus défavorisées
voilà tout ça ça fait partie de
l'écologie politique on recréer du lien
social dans les quartiers mettre en
place des actions des conseils de
citoyens des conseils de quartier des
conseils de proximité pour essayer de
trouver des solutions ensemble